hey there folks
halo 5 time i'm chris waters
and i'm rob handler yeah and you can
handle that one yourself i can hey rob
how's it going it's going great you're
gonna play some halo yeah we are uh we
played this like two hours
two months ago so
uh now you are all going to get played
pretty soon december 29th the proper
beta starts but we've got some special
early access uh thanks for the friends
uh over at three four four
uh is that the right number it's three
four three
yes we're gonna miss
we're gonna jump into the arena
multiplayer beta oh yeah
currently
only one gameplay mode available i
believe slayer just slayer it's team
player team slayer 4v4 and uh currently
only a small amount of maps that are
going to be deployed in the full beta
there's going to be more game modes more
maps but
today you're going to get a look at
slayer in action i think there's two
maps we can get into
and you get to see all the new movement
abilities in halo 5 because there's a
bunch
talking side dashes
side dashes i was i played a game just
before a little bit warmed up and uh
there's a nice hovering mode that was uh
that was working out you basically aim
and you hover in place the aim down
sights hover yeah there's also the uh
ground pound
just jump
aim kind of you kind of aim yourself
like a little missile it's not like
instant like a butt stomp right it's
just like
and you like have this reticle on the
ground and then you just your rockets
kick in and you just jet down there yeah
it's fun we'll try to pull some antics
for you guys yeah and uh we're getting
into the chat here on gamespot and on
twitch it's not on gamespot on
both
confirmed
so if you have any questions about it or
want to see anything or have us do
certain moves or just just chat in
general if you want to just stare at a
wall and look at the textures
oh yeah i can do that we will we will
show you any texture you want yeah
but yeah so we're in a fire team uh
currently searching for players the we
were able to download this earlier so we
got it all queued up the 1pm
of course our live stream start time is
when they said uh
it's gonna go up uh you were actually in
a match earlier like just a few minutes
ago but right now there's a lot of
people trying to get into some matches
so
searching for players that's what we're
doing it was fun i've got the the sound
is pretty great like
all the like pistol shots sounded really
nice i don't know
did they do that like i feel like
in a series the only direction that like
game sounds tend to take is like burlier
nastier like more harsh and metallic
right was that kind of uh definitely
yeah there's definitely some of that
kind of what it was doing some metal
pounding
so these are going to be the weapons i
mean what are we going to see here rob
get some battle rifle yeah it's there's
halo 4. uh i love the dmr that's one of
my favorites ooh loading uh pistols
there
you know assault rifle classic here we
go
all right
so
there you see the center of the map
where the power weapons spawn uh there's
actually like a big indicator that shows
you where that is you'll see it
uh and here we go here we go baby
okay remember what buttons do
okay so yeah the dash is b
and that's a dash forward that's a dash
to the side right and you get kind of
like a like one go at it i've been
killed
by a dmr or a br it looks like a dmr
all right oh look check this out clamber
there's a new smg not right rob
uh yeah i'm using that right now
nice
well there's a lot of dudes up here so
let's clear that area four guys up there
i'm not going off maybe i shouldn't go
in there with a sprint charge is what
you're saying i got a grenade kill uh
screw it i got s worded
oh that was close got a little smgz
let's see some other new abilities here
so like check this out
this is when i start sprinting you'll
notice boom that little bracket pops up
that means whenever i want to now i can
melee and do that sort of charge melee
attack uh you can you can sprint
infinitely
in halo 5 guardians but while you are
sprinting you will not be regenerating
shields right
a little flank
i think i got one oh i got a short sword
guy sure he freaking meleed me but i
gotta kill
dmr
here we go
oh man another sword guy huh
oh come on up i know you're oh yeah
there you are i see you
and i'm dead
assault rifle don't do me wrong
assist i'll take it i gotta keep my mind
on that dash i gotta use that here's
some things to notice all right what's
the uh
what's the like error
stomp move it's jumping it's crouched
yeah click the stick exactly yeah all
right so this is what it is you go you
jump you click the stick the target
comes up and then you release it to
stomp down i'll try to use that on
somebody but uh not now when i'm dead
not when you are good
how are we doing here terribly
i'm not doing too hot that's fine
there's a kill
we should uh team up i'm gonna follow
you
so i'm uh hot
i see sure that's your service tag
that's my service tag and also your
current temperature situation
exactly also your estimation of your own
physical attractiveness
not a modest man thanks for clearing
that up
all right
melee sprint do the melee sprint nope
didn't do it i wonder
i thought i was trying to sprint and
maybe my sprint was getting interrupted
there it is
oh okay all right
man i'm racking up the assists now i
remember when we played it i was
not really into that hovering
but now that i'm using it
it's pretty useful like just to kind of
change it up you know like
so the hover again if you're watching
robbie's been doing it uh
you just basically jump and aim down
sights and then you do this kind of like
hover thing
and you know it makes you vulnerable for
sure because it's kind of hanging up
there but where it was really coming in
clutch is this is um kind of avoiding a
grenade like someone tosses grenade
you can kind of
you know take off some of that
like they anticipate where you're gonna
land
i can't talk too they anticipate where
you're gonna land right and throw their
grenade and then you disrupt that by
oh i gotta start using my dash ability a
lot i'm totally forgetting it's like oh
crap there's all of them here oh yeah
dash away no that was me dying not
dashing
damn it
i was killed by some jerk some stuff to
notice about the hud uh you got your
mini map on the bottom left and above it
it's showing you
it's telling you what little like what
area of the map you're in
uh
so i'm i'm top mid right now oh god
and see that was sprinting and to get
away but not also losing shields
not also regenerating shield because i
was sprinting so that's the bottom left
bottom right you got your your score
your 50 kills to win
it's match timer a little indicator of
what
team you are if you can't see your own
hands
which you know
show you what team you're on smg
top right got your weapons and your gun
and ammo and then sort of silhouetted
behind that your alternate weapon
that you got that was close damn it and
how much ammo you got for that one
and across the top it's
the shields
oh crubs
the shield and the health damn
i think it's you know it's all
regenerating uh
as in previous
but more recent halos
come on get grenaded
got one
so this smart what is it called smart
link i think is what they actually call
the aim down sights because every weapon
has it like even the assault rifle has
got and it's just i think the smart link
part is it just like links uh
the idea is that it
it's linking to your hud something like
that oh come
here no
it's linking to like your hud and that's
why there's a scope not because the
weapon itself has a scope
we're not doing terrible i mean i am but
i'm all right
from behind buddy hey friend
oh nope oh i blew it
i don't know how that guy got me i feel
like we were shooting each other the
same amount but isn't that always the
question
how did your enemy kill you how do you
avoid getting killed in a similar
fashion in the future
damn it
they all came after me rob ah
i gotta agree to allow that one i feel
like we should stick together yeah look
through that where are your uh hello
man gdz
all right they're coming up
oh wait
god
every guy wants to definitely should
have let my shield regenerate there
come on
all right this little warm up
all right getting warmed up yeah so then
they have these little end of match
things all these spartans looking the
same because you don't really have any
options on how to customize your
character yet oh yeah but you can make
your sweet pippy there's gonna be a ton
oh oh look there we go air assault
is how now my face can be
yeah let me put on that air assault all
right so it it's showing your experience
here of how much you're gaining
towards your persistent rank uh and
that's gonna be uh
just continually going up kind of thing
not a not a loot
gain some lose some however the
competitive skill rating is coming back
in like a more
surfaced way than it has been in
previous halos because it's sort of been
an under the hood thing uh in
matchmaking in previous halos
it's the rank that basically can go up
and down halo 2 style um except it
you know
people don't like seeing a number go up
and down
when they lose so i think the the
competitive skill rank sort of puts it
uh
in this case it's going to allow you to
see where you're at
see how you go up and down and also
see where your opponents are at
presumably
but
it takes a little while to hone in on
your competitive skill ranks so i have
eight matches left to qualify
which you would see if the game feed was
on my there it is
so yeah see like not qualified on the
playlist that is a competitive skill
rating so um
i guess play a bunch of matches yeah
here it is
right here thank you rob josh for that
transport
i'm not qualified
to play on that playlist
but soon i will be i don't know if it's
actually going to be in the beta but
maybe
yeah did you put on your helmet
it wasn't there assault
wasn't there do i have to open it up i
don't know man
roster you go to your spartan service
record
visor
is that separate than a helmet
no yes yeah oh yeah
it's not there recruit well i have these
guard
it's scarred because uh
you know it's got those patches
you've been through some stuff these
this helmet looks like it's been through
some stuff you see how it's like way
more low-res than the other
well i mean it's a beta man yeah it's a
it's a real beta situation it's the
actual helmet from halo 2. well look
yeah it actually kind of oh yeah it's
like that's what they called all
graphical fidelity yeah but yeah this
one looks sharp
the recruit job
why am i pink i guess it's red
technically
cool
all right back in this matchmaking for
some halo 5 guardians uh
so
yeah
new multiplayer mode you know this i
feel like they're really trying to
push this halo
in terms of uh getting it up to i don't
know
up to current
sort of the current zeitgeist of gaming
of competitive shooters which is that
call of duty
dash mobility that titanfall wall run
that uh
that kind of
expanded physical capabilities not just
uh working on the gun play and the
different weapon balance so
you have the
b button as we have it mapped yeah to
thrust or dash in any direction at any
time uh so if you see a lunge that's
there
and then there's a sprint thing which we
mentioned earlier
you can sprint like all the time if you
want
there's also the sprint
what they call that it's kind of like
spartan charge spartan charge which
someone whipped that on me i was
intimidating did you get spartan charge
oh yeah flu
but if you
charge someone in the face
it's not an instant kill
like it's a duck their shields and then
you gotta shoot them yeah
but if you charge them in the back
instant kill yeah
empire so we played this one oh the
sniper
yeah so this one had um indications of
like when the heavy weapons would be
spawning i think it's the like they're
currently uh they're currently up
i'm going for the sniper
here we go
let me know if anyone's coming up with
your face
i'd say i keep clicking my stick to aim
but it's not well there are left trigger
yeah i mean there are options yeah sure
you can go back for how to change your
button loadouts and such all right
guys back there with like a br
show yourself
all right all right
so this is the new smg that i have uh
you guys got to look at it a little bit
fires like that pretty
uh speedy
there it is
doing work
this is up here is a really good place
to work your uh oh you're like stomp
game
yeah
oh they're over there with the sniper
now yeah this is where you out of uh no
he came behind me and uh snapping that
kind of thing
yeah this is definitely the map to do
the ground pound
oh couldn't pull aside our mountain time
yeah
double double it
all right rob all right rob
here we go
there we go
i'm on it
practice ground pound real quick
nope
i don't like that engagement length you
have a battle rifle
now i have a battle rifle oh
oh it was not loaded properly
dang it
is that your shield
noise
yeah it was
i
there you are hello friend hello here
they come on the right
ground pound oh
damn we tried it did you try doing it we
both i both try to do it i
what is it again so it's it's just you
jump and crouch
you just immediately jump and crouch you
hold it no uh yes you jump you hold it
you jump
yeah you got to hold the crouch
all right who's grabbing that sniper
here we go watch this
get it
he was afk but whatever count it
it's still fun still fun
oh what's up buddy
where are you at rob where are you at oh
i need some help i'm here all right
let's see i just dashed it out it was
perfect
there you are i see it
oh
you're right i traded
all right
but yeah starting to use the dash
definitely more it's
definitely
starting to feel it starting to get
there a little bit
i'm just going to start sprinting around
now and oh yeah oh eat it do it
crab cup crap i gotta flick
the flanking
all right let's let's uh team up again
let's see where you're at i'm coming oh
sniper rifle yeah i don't know if i do
i'm sniping here we go
it's not not a
great oh no
are you over there damn
i just like
my melee
distance is not well calibrated these
are all the things like when you go
shooter to shooter right right right you
gotta get calibrated too right so yeah
my melee distance was not on point there
charging run sprint attack come back
here get him i see him
i definitely spartan charges that dude
too dead but there were like two more
oh yeah
see that
nicely done
i liked it yeah
uh so what do you think these sound
effects like definitely feeling them
like
going for the burlier oh yeah kind of
thing right
oh you missed buddy
that was a spartan charge that went awry
and i took advantage
oh we are crushing these dudes yay
glorious victory
all right
ah
he's taking some of the sights here
uh yep this door is all messed up cool
yeah
got some grenades haven't really been
using those let's try to stick someone
with it let's see what a new plasma
grenade looks like
i haven't even used one okay
probably
actually kill dudes instead of doing the
scenic tour
damn blew that
nope
i think i like crouching oh it's stuck
to your leg on the bounce
power weapons were up back to the snipe
back
not that much
where are they how's your sniping game
rob
i was doing all right
um i used to be obsessed with sniping
like halo 1 i was
that was my thing
definitely across the way
all right messed up this one dude over
here
wow he's coming for me
so i kind of got like half a ground
pound if you land
somewhat near them you you'll do some
splash damage
let's try it again no i flew it
is that you
oh yeah air tastes fine i keep
forgetting that get it oh yeah there's
your shield and yeah
successful ground pounding so yeah like
i think you can you know with those
melee abilities like they're gonna be
deadly if you come if you get like the
you get from behind but otherwise
you're gonna need to uh just pop them in
the head one time
just stick around for that grenade oh
yeah get these just nice nicely done
uh let's get a little skybox look here
okay yeah
that thing
um
cities i don't know where this is
earth maybe
somewhere somewhere else okay
hello friend
oh
someone was shooting me i don't know who
it was
it was you
oh there's two oh i see it
you're getting away from them
oh
i am aborting i dashed in when i should
have dashed out yeah that's the other
one that's the better one to do in that
case
not in my watch
who wants to get sprint charged
you do you do you do i see you i see you
hello friend
oh no i couldn't finish it off
oh
he made me in the ankle when i jumped
away
oh
nice grenade
damn
god some of these areas are so dark i
don't know if you guys can tell on
stream i mean
yeah the deep darks of course that's
like a gamma adjustment thing i'm not
sure if the beta actually has that in it
we can check it take a look at some of
the options after
get punched oh as far as settings
options yeah there weren't many
whatsoever yeah i mean that's typical
for a beta sure i mean just controller
settings i think that's about it but
this is uh
count it
it's totally like the nfl guy leave me a
high five like we did rob oh man oh that
was fun i did i did nicely
let's check all these stats huh
oh 20 kills
five death 4.0 kdr
nicely done go for it
you win the slayer and you're feeling
yourself all right
take a look at some of your medals man
can you is there like metal dish
um
let's see
because you earned 37 of them my friend
where do you check those things out i
don't know service record shows
your tool destruction
your stats of how long you've played
your win percentage etc career overview
there's no way to drill down on that
stuff
gamer card
i don't know maybe we'd have to back out
of matchmaking to see that would make
sense
huh
that well
that was fun
want to take a look at some controller
settings yeah no i'm already there bro
oh my skin
different button layouts southpaw boxer
green thumb bumper jumper recon fish
take halo 4.
wow all the all the usuals
maybe i don't know what you're just
doing
the usual i don't know
uh
crouch clench protection and sprint via
button so like
you can just activate your sprint and
not have to hold it down
it's like a toggle sprint i guess once
printing press the sprint button stops
the sprint which i
will say no too i don't like that at all
auto stabilize automatically maintain
position during smart link which is the
aim down sights in midair when set to on
press the sprint button to stabilize
during smart link when set to off
i'm not sure what stabilize means
might just mean like stabilize like does
it like lock it in in the direction
you're pointing
i don't know hold the clamber maybe is
that like a kind of like a back to like
turning auto stabilize off oh i forgot
we had chat here look at the chat man
chris and his look and version i agree
look at that one what it was it was a
smiley face after it right it was a
thumbs up it was like a picture of an a
number one award
for being a rad dude with good taste
and a correct
okay sorry you're good
this isn't worth it
someone needs to get that sword i want
to see that in action
if you go for it i can cover you
oh i'm actually there i think
dude do it oh i didn't call i blew it
all right let's give it a shot we've
lost the lead rob
well hopefully this sword will change
that
do you have it yep
oh
oh it what
two grenades
that was just the one grenade and i
shoot to kill oh i got four of them on
me oh boy
am i coming
let's try it out
nope
a chance should have
yeah i keep engaging with this assault
rifle i think i shouldn't do that dude i
am a dmr fan
all right i'm following you all right
let's just do some sweeps
just hug this wall
run around this here midship
that yeah
mid chip this was like a midshipmap
yeah midship this map actually looks
pretty great
oh they're across
let's keep going still there
here we go
yeah he stole a lot
of grenade
goddammit gold tupac
get blown up oh no there's two of them
oh one on your belt
so it's interesting it shows you uh when
you die it shows you the amount of
shield and the amount of health that
your opponent had oh you see that
i did not see that oh that's a double
but hopefully the viewers did oh that
was awesome
i did a stat uh we call it again
gosh keep forgetting these names
the what's the pound
how would they call it pound slam slam
pound brought spartan
stomp stomp stomp
i don't actually know what it's called
whatever the hell it is i just did one
of those two guys and then mopped it up
oh it was too close to engage
i wonder if i distracted him though
distraction
that's my favorite medal because the
guy's got his tongue sticking out
i dropped my two from nades
oh
oh no the worst punch fight i saw that
let me get a
stombo
oh crap where did that come from
that's weird i guess you can dash up
there yeah he like i guess you can climb
up through the middle
up guy coming up
get bomb
oh i got bombed but i got him
tracy's
all right rob let's
what moves are we gonna try oh i gotta
work on this this like auto stabilize
yeah what is that
uh it's so the auto stabilize is the uh
hover right
so basically if you wanna be able to
jump and aim down sights but not
go into the hover mode
so you i guess maybe
how would you even turn it on then if
you're going to turn it off you click
sprint so if you don't want to go like
the
the aim down sights in the air puts you
into this hover mode by default but if
you don't you can turn off auto
stabilize that is interesting and then
you can just activate it by uh
aiming down sights and sprinting so it's
not you're not removing the ability to
do the thing
you're just uh
doing it in a different way
all right it's coming up the warp thing
okay
come on oh make a bad decision oh
is this a thing no
yes it is oh god where are they
yeah we're doing we're doing good nice
this is a close match
the dmr's are normally all swords up
let's get the sword oh okay let me uh
let me tell you do you want to get it oh
[__]
oh that was a good grenade
nice go for the zord go for it
all right there to the right over here
coming around
oh you're getting in there
no where's the sword pull it out use it
ah geez throw up pull up i got it i got
it i got it okay i need all right there
he's upstairs
i'm doing it
all right hello friends
no the great oh i walked right onto it
dash away that's your way look at it
grenade vision i hate grenade vision
it's so cheeky just like hey what's up
i'm a little bomb i'm gonna came in here
to kill you you want to sleep
i avenged you but also dead from it
let that be a lesson to you folks
revenge
tear your world apart
maybe i don't know
did you get that dimmer up there like i
will say like i love the dmr but if i
wanted to use that hovering mode
i wouldn't prefer to go
like i'd rather not aim down sides for
that
i played
step directly on that oh the dmr oh
you're gone didn't get my shield back in
time
you get them get them yeah
yeah
i take that back kids vengeance is dope
do it all the time
and where's the shoddy i haven't seen
that yet
boom
what did you do
oh
i just spartan charged someone in the
dome who was killing our teammate
what's what's a spartan charge again how
do you do that sprint and then melee
okay
oh that's great two over here i gotta
use that i haven't done it yet you could
uh
oh where are you at no i mean they i
think they went elsewhere
with tay over here what is that beeping
crap sick is that me
i think
ah that was stupid
yeah so the charge you gotta get into a
full sprint you can't just like whip it
out whenever you go of course you got to
get into a phone no and that's the basic
premise of the move just you know i'm
sorry talking to myself i don't want to
be so intense i just lost a dmr fight
it's okay about it it's okay
here we go
it up with the ground pound
damn
worth it
that was really good you just came
rocketing in my peripheral oh did i go
like over your head you're just like off
my shoulder okay
i'm going for the sword oh
no you're dead already
that is probably one of the most
rewarding moves
with the ground pond yeah
respect delay one more kill oh really i
want it
sword guy wants it so are you guys gonna
get it
yes
you eviscerated try admiral
what's up spartan dudes hey guys thanks
for watching we're playing uh halo 5
guardians beta got some early access to
it uh thanks to the folks at microsoft
in 343. uh the proper beta itself starts
on december 29th and runs through
january 15th it's about three weeks a
little less
math
little less than three weeks
but
every week that passes they're going to
introduce more modes
more maps up to i think seven modes and
three maps
maps
three modes seven maps uh
so right now we're playing slayer on two
of the maps truth the one you just saw
which is like midship from halo 2 and
then the other one is empire which maybe
we'll be in next
uh the only other map that we played
during our time with the game about a
month ago
was sort of like this tron meets forge
situation that was like remember the
name of it purely like
competitive based like it looked like a
paintball court you know it's got like
weird triangles and stuff like set up
for you to hide behind
and so that's one of the other maps that
we'll presumably see
we've also got um
what the other mode which is uh i forget
the name of it but it's basically a
round based mode where
a match is
first to five rounds like
everyone it's four on four when you die
you're dead you don't respawn
the last in each team you know whoever
team survives
kills the other team gets a point first
five points wins
just repeats round after round those can
get pretty tense really tense
uh it's eric tay walking by
getting psyched about a shoulder charge
we did because he's playing with us as
chocolate miyak
uh it's pretty fun yeah it's feeling
pretty good pretty good i gotta be
honest we played this in the preview rob
and i got our butts kicked a little bit
yeah right there there were some sharks
yeah and it it took until definitely a
couple of the last rounds before some
some damage was done but
yeah it was it was fun
it's going up well so so far yeah we're
two for three uh what's chat saying they
gonna have any questions here yeah if
you guys got any questions questions
chatted
just on gamespot or twitch.tv gamespot
that's right intermission has been over
at zero for a little bit now i don't
know if we should back out and uh try to
join another match we'll just wait maybe
like 30 more seconds and see
oh look it's got hit percentage
that's kind of neat
neat new stat
my percentage
was not very good
gold tupac on the opposing team hitting
over
over one out of every every two shots
amazing
let's let's not oversell it all right
the average life was 28 seconds
oh man
kill death ratio i like it oh i'm gonna
switch you know i don't like his uh
toggle crouch
you're a hold crouch kind of guy yeah
i mean i'm only doing it for like a
moment i just hate clicking out of it
or like accidentally clicking it like
you know you're crouched and you're like
slow slowed down
life is hard rob it is full of trials
and tribulations it's rough
i'm digging the clamber kind of yeah but
i and i feel like i could use it in more
situations like if i
think about it
more
empire
this is a clamorable level let's try to
work some clambers try to get some
ground pounds
i got some i gotta get some charges in
also there are like a whole suite of
armor abilities a la jet pack and such
that you saw in like halo 4 yeah uh
those are not that the the thruster
abilities are kind of the replacement
for those
all right uh i guess i'll grab this
sniper rifle because no one else is
around to
and it's important to hold on to things
like this
three of them just for me
three is a big number of guys to take
down by yourself oh come on
all right where are you at
and i definitely pressed the wrong
button i see yeah we'll mop them up
don't you worry about it there's a
sniper rifle there if you want to grab
it don't get um trying to do the ground
pound but i keep it's the click it's
click the freaking stick yeah
i i mean is it the click or is it hold
it oh yeah it's holding i think it's a
whole yeah okay all right yeah
yeah i know that's why i was fleeing
you didn't know about me
oh shoot
oh didn't you didn't dash away in time
got the grenade cam
we need cam
you rocking that pistol at all i kind of
like it i am yeah i think precision
weapons i mean
from time to time uh
yeah precision weapons are pretty oh we
got two in the middle
what's up buddy no i was not that was
terrible that was just really a bad move
still almost managed to get him but he
definitely ran away from me because he
saw me up there like
all right we're down a little bit
i'm coming to you
come around the side here
come on in buddy
all right here he comes here he comes
all right
good team
good teamwork i agree oh yeah so that's
definitely gonna talk about they uh yeah
your dudes will like say stuff that's
like contextual
automatically so it'll they'll say like
enemies got the power weapons or
something or good teamwork
wow
or even like it just told me i was
four-shotted
wait
yeah i've even heard it's descriptive
i've even heard like
um
like out of ammo or something like that
or reload reloading yeah i just heard
that there
was me so yeah it's i think what they
what they're trying to do with that uh
the guys at 344 were saying is
like approximate the kind of
chatter that a competitive team uh does
to each other with each other mine is
yep
oh
nice there's a no sculptor oh oh
a little help
uh oh i almost got him
yeah keep going sorry oh no
uh so
343 industries is really into the sort
of esports angle with halo 5 and so
you know that's surfacing the names of
each area that you're in that's uh
creating modes that are tuned
specifically for like balanced
competitive play and it's also
making your spartans say stuff that like
a competitive team would say to each
other
uh just naturally ground pound
boom
how about you over there people come to
me
uh
so you know just to kind of increase
that general battlefield awareness about
saying you're reloading saying there's
an enemy in this area saying the power
weapons are up etc uh
that kind of awareness they're trying to
put a little bit of that in that into
the game with the ai
oh with the automatic voice stuff
i talk real good when shooting and
getting grenade deaded you're much
better than me all right well we're even
now so that's a good match this is a
match oh ouchies
a lot of nades
i don't think somebody yeah
on my turn
damn it i gotta say yeah
i get into a stick
that is really fun
that is
really
i mean it's certainly not always
practical definitely can get you into
trouble yeah uh if you
push your advantage too much but
a bunch of guys come to you
yeah missed it
oh i just did it again
my face got exploded oh yeah
rob dude
eric
saw that you're awesome
i like the clambering i like being able
to like
mess with where the enemy expects me to
be coming from even if it's just like
through a window that's slightly to the
side
yeah
yeah yeah i do like that
here we go here we go come on baby
duck the shield got him
you can actually do this the pound like
sooner than
than i thought
i was able to get one off like like much
quicker
much quicker than like previously
don't worry i just terrified that person
by shooting whole bullets all around
their head
they don't feel safe anymore
their sense of security in the world is
shaken they might not be actually
more wounded
no
that was that didn't go well there were
weird situations
yeah again i'll keep my eye on the chat
you guys have any questions i'll help
you out
shouldn't have clambered up here bro
i'm clambering to my zone i'll watch
this here we go try to do a sniper
not super good at tonight that was what
did you just sniper headshot and it said
triple kill did it yeah because it kind
of
did you just like kill three dudes i
don't actually don't yes maybe maybe i
don't i don't know i just been killing
guys left and right i can't keep track
oh [__]
ah reversal i like that
because the dude had the drop on me and
i ran and then got
got him well and truly grenaded
uh and it gave me the reversal metal
oh
man who's got one of those charges
blew it
wherever that goes
oh all right game over
all right highlight of the match for you
rob what do you got what'd you do you
got some ground pounds
yeah the ground pound was great the
ground pound's fun i think when
you did some sniping business i did a
little sniping when you did one and i
followed through right after it was
awesome
oh you got your air assault chest well
if we can put it on that maybe didn't
show up
yeah rob tearing it up 19 and 8.
oh let me see
death sentence 91 when is the release
date for this game
um
no november next november right i don't
know i don't think it's technically
november it's next holiday they're going
to get it out so
you've got to imagine that's like
october november uh but i don't think
they've said the
date specifically yet
in fact i'm pretty sure they have not
tip isn't it like is it has every
release been on the 11th isn't that like
the typical halo thing
right
as i know like
halo 2 was the 11th
i mean 11 11 is a pretty
catchy date
you know i thought they've always done
that uh
uh baby choo choo i just started
watching what's the general feeling so
far liking it meh what
i put it to you rob
general feeling so far is i know i love
you know i i actually haven't played
call of duty advanced warfare lately but
i i like the mobility i like moving
around getting frantic that's always
kind of how i played
shooters in general you know like faking
out people and and such
so having this
dash i like it almost a little better in
that you don't you know there aren't
i feel like call of duty will escalate
to where people are just dashing all the
time
this is something where you get
you get one and you get to use it
you know it's it's time sensitive like
you can't just bust that out the
cooldown is definitely longer on the
halo 5 guardians dash right yeah
and at least as it is in the beta yeah
and i love that i love like a dash in
dash out
um
option
um yeah i mean
it works for me and i like i like even
the uh
the hover stabilizer that's always great
have you been using that i haven't been
using that like at all a lot if i'm
coming into a room
or if i know a guy's coming around the
corner i'll be up here you'll just jump
oh yeah just and just hang out here so
he's like he comes around expecting me
to be level yeah oh no i mean and then
he i have the upper hand yeah you've got
a second yeah you've got a split second
drop on him right and then you know you
do that for a moment and then you drop
and what's once he you know the idea is
he's constantly trying to move so like
once he tries to get you know the
crosshair on your face you just drop
down
um
so that's great
um i i like it it's it still does feel
like halo as well
in my opinion yeah that's it that's all
that's got to be that's always the
challenge right when you've got a series
like this that has such momentum behind
it uh in terms of the
feel that people expect from it the feel
that they want from it yeah you got to
make it
make it the same but different yeah
and i hope they don't incorporate like
i were we ever a fan of the orange drops
hold on let's just take a look at why
this map is called truth that was the
prophet of truth
little hover guy
i was i was paying my respects and then
i got killed rude uh but
sorry what were you saying i was from
that dash
and i threw a grenade by accident
i need help
uh what i was saying oh ordinance drops
before yeah did you
enjoy that
uh you know what it was like a basically
it's basically how power weapon would
come into halo 4 right right and it was
it was just score based so you know
you eventually would accumulate enough
and then you'd get one
i just felt it was kind of like
just like an overkill i mean
it did get pretty intense with the uh
like the lng
right specifically that was definitely
like a a weapon that was
much more intense than any other weapon
on the field uh
i mean i i kind of oh crap
yeah there's a sword guy running around
i thought it was kind of neat i liked
the armor abilities more in halo 4. i
thought that the
you know and those are obviously from
reach like it'd been around for a little
bit but
uh
i oh one coming in oh sort
i got him ah good
i have avenged thee
i just oh you know
going back to early halo you know like
the same playing field is always is
always
crap um something i've enjoyed
i feel like this is like when you start
and everyone has the same weapon yeah
same weapon and
i mean
there are those moments where it's like
oh there's not a chance i'm gonna like
win this
scenario you've got like an overshield
um
you don't appreciate that or you know i
i mean like that because like it happens
sometimes
yeah the occasional right like
i guess map pickups are always cool but
if someone's like
wrecking shop
and he just keeps getting ordinance
drops
oh the smg
mean
mean business
what's going on here
oh
uh why is everyone dead over here i feel
very uneasy
crap
all right it's time to do some what some
moves here i got triple team there oh so
he's he was just doing that too that
hover that was cool
he and i were kindred hover hover man
buddies
someone just you saved me like oh who
did that sort of snipe
uh yeah i got a long shot kill that was
awesome i think that was you
saved my ass you're welcome
i lost my ass shortly thereafter
i'll go anywhere
oh i'm in a tight spot
oh boy
someone is really enjoying their smg
adorable
oh there's like a ramp up to the middle
i'm not doing too hot
oh that's interesting oh yeah that's
that's remember that like we played the
match earlier and some guy just like
came out of nowhere he climbed up that
um
structure
here we go
it's a party in that room
and i'm out
get dmr perfect kill some chat asked if
the pistol still a three shot kill and i
would say definitely not
but it is pretty solid
um that was a long shot melee kill by
the way
hello friend bet you didn't know there
was a sword in play
there is that's the song that's a real
thing oh man
all right chance
all right let's warm up
oh [__] i do not want to engage right
now
what you were alive i just did the
chopping
damn it that was not good
that was our chance
this one's coming up all right rob oh no
sword
sword liz sword
the sword's got a different design
i got a hail mary kill for that long
range grenade throw
love it
all right here we go
move in
we're going across the mid yeah we are
russian mid russian mid oh i went i went
down below
i see him
i'm going for a dmr up here
that's great
picked up the dmr
all right they're all coming
okay to us okay yeah let's wave them
on the right huh yep
get punched
your life oh we gained the lead
stay tight
stay frosty start crossing my crown oh
that's our buddy
uh so that's another thing you'll notice
when i was just firing there with the
battle rifle uh d-scoping is a thing
so if you are scoping in damn it and you
get shot
uh
you'll get popped right out of it so
like even if there's a sniper far away
oh two kills to win we're tied at 48.
this is tunes
yeah oh no down
oh no
oh
really close
gg everybody gg other team
all right guys all right fair enough i
did not do that well
uh
so was that fun so i was playing halo
one on master chief collection and
that was
that was in there was um
you know if you're aiming down any kind
of site and you get shot at you you pop
out
yep but that was not in that has not
been in all halos let's see
i stopped after one
i don't know exactly when it stopped or
when it uh
yeah i don't know
all right
guys
that was a solid hour of halo 5
guardians beta
what do you think
are you interested are you gonna get
into the beta and decide for yourself
when it starts on december 29th uh are
you off that halo train are you
on it for life like this guy
i'm back on you're back on yeah i i love
it that's fun
it was pretty neat yeah uh you know i'm
not sure you know
yeah it was pretty neat that was fun
there's some good there's some good a
good crisp feel to it some uh the
weapons felt pretty nice right uh
the thrill of like
the whole the whole like shield then no
shield go for the headshot like a
dichotomy of a halo firefight is what
always has made halo firefights seem
more substantial and more
engaging to me than in any other
competitive multiplayer shooter uh so
i'm a fan if you guys have any questions
about it feel free to hit us up on
twitter i'm ct waters he's robert
handlery is that right it's just your
straight up name it's my straight up
full name full name
and uh yeah
beta starts properly on the 29th
and i hope you guys get in there we'll
maybe see you there
hey cool thanks for watching happy
holidays everybody take care now
you